all
right uh keeps relationship private oh
uh I'm guessing in what context uh I'm
guessing just they kind of like separate
their relationship to kind of like other
aspects of their lives so so they're you
know someone who kind of like hangs out
with their friends oh like when you're
like you're hang around a friend and
then he's like oh by the way I've been
in a relationship for like 8 months
you're like what yeah yeah yeah like
that or or like more more like you know
the hang out with their friends and they
just don't like talk about their partner
at all or um oh as in like they keep
their relationships out of matters that
don't exactly call yeah yeah so so you
know that if you're dating a person so
the opposite of that would be someone
who's like oh yeah that was really cool
by the way my boyfriend someone is
constantly just like pushing in their
own so so so the way I interpret this is
okay so you're dating someone they will
never talk to you uh they would never
talk about you to their friends outside
of oh outside of is that the you guys
meant with this one yeah yeah okay okay
okay okay I'm trying to discern like
that's not a lot of work with yeah um I
don't really have crazy okay
um oh man this is
hard so they don't go out of their way
to talk about their relationship to
other people yeah and just so I guess
what if okay but what if like someone
comes up to that person and is like
how's your boyfriend or girlfriend and
they talk about it is that I think a
normal thing is just like someone who
just doesn't really mention you kind of
like unnecessarily unnecessarily this is
such a Vibe check kind of thing it's so
hard to know yeah I I guess this very
much keeps relationship private cuz I
could see multiple different
people who have this kind of thing and
it would be very very different with
each person how the vi would it really
depends on the personality but there's
like Jeffrey Dharma kind of private
where you're like oh and then you're
like you know that was the worst example
well you know some you're like that's
why is he keeping it so private that's
so concerning you know I'd understand if
my boyfriend was a serial killer but you
know it'd be a little bit more
understanding they they got something hi
literally all right I'm ready all 3 2 1
none none yeah don't this is such a case
by case thing it's whatever you know
like if if Ari wants to go around
[__] talking about me to her
girlfriends or doesn't at all I it
doesn't really change my [__] thing I
didn't even think of this from like my
perspec I think from like friend's
perspective like if if da didn't talk
about Sydney ever I would be like well
think about it with your partner oh I
don't think I'd care that much i' I
would care like as long as you as long
as you uh they know I exist right you're
the family right they know I'm real
right I'm a real boyfriend yeah yeah I
mean like there's plenty of reasons to
want to separate your love life from
like other aspects of your life um and
some reason who really wants to shout to
the world about their love life and I
respect both I don't really care you
know seriously how you do it yeah about
person I think yeah I think there's a
right way to do it and there's a
definitely a wrong way to do it yeah
what what I what I think is a red flag
is uh kind of like someone who
unprompted says every little intimate
part of like their relationship to like
everyone it's like yeah this meal is
great it kind of reminds me of the time
my boyfriend [__] me in the ass you
know like it's like whoa all right I
didn't even know
next
promp uh believes in conspiracy
theories okay okay well this
is I hope to God we all have the same
answer for this 3 2 1 it's red okay it's
red it's a very very concerning trait to
not be able to discern like [__]
online yeah and in general yeah I feel
that's just someone who is incredibly
gullible to a dangerous level and that
can sneak into all other parts of the
relationship that could be dangerous I I
don't even think it's gullible man I
just think it's like a it's we're we
live in a really tough time yeah where I
think a lot of people uh you fall for a
lot of things I'm sure we all have
fallen for something at some point one
or another but it's about being able to
like educate yourself and know when
you're when you're wrong and learn when
you've been fed misinformation or
[__] um I want to date a
freethinking person not a sheep all
right well you know a lot of people I
wake up sheep a lot of people I care
about my life i' found out when they
they'd say something I'm like oh no you
you believe something that is wrong yeah
and this is I don't know how to feel
about this like food poisoning is not an
illness well that's that's not it's not
a theory joke it's the truth okay I mean
wake
upy
upy it kind of depends on uh like if I
heard this instant like my gut feeling
is a red flag uh obviously not even just
as a partner just as someone I want to
be associated with you yeah yeah yeah
it's it's like a big thing is that how
how big of a conspiracy are we talking
here are we talking about cuz there's
lots of like little conspiracies where
it doesn't have like that much of an
effect on the way that someone thinks
about the last thing that I can think
about that really kind of tested this
was uh the co vaccine like a lot of a
lot of people when it came out right
like CU a lot of people that's true when
it initially came out they were like oh
I just don't know if I feel good about a
vaccine that was made so fast which was
a sentiment that was very very popular
uh and and and it made this really weird
thing where people who normally would
never like be conspiratorial kind of got
reading kind of pieces online that kind
of more aligned with that theory and
reasons why and it was a really like
kind of sad time really where a lot of
people that was the day where everyone
collectively cleaned out their like
Facebook friends closet it was it was it
was a really like I know immediately it
was really like [__] up time and I
think that it was like the perfect storm
to get people who would never never like
think this kind of way who would kind of
go down some rabbit holes they wouldn't
have gone down um it was just sad that
just made me sad yeah yeah yeah I mean I
think like I said it very much depends
on the level of what kind of conspiracy
are they believing in is it something
like [__] flat earthers or something
like 5G chips 5G chips okay obviously
red flag is it something a bit more fun
like oh there are aliens in like Area 51
or something like that you know which is
I believe that you can
be all right
based on facts from the Navy seen it you
can you can talk about conspiracy
theories in a fun fun way yeah but if
but seriously believing a lot of these
things is I think is just bad and
dangerous as well if especially if
you're going to have kids and going tell
them [__] absolutely going to make other
kids who are [__] Dum totally
yeah yeah I I think it's one thing to
entertain the thought of conspiracy
theories it's another thing to like
fully commit to it yeah uh oh we only
got a few left in here might have to
stock up soon we're going through these
way too fast no I I we have all right
next
one
uh they like horror too much I put this
one in yeah I can see
why I G and I feel a Target on our backs
right now wow this is this is a personal
attack this is this is a goddamn
personal
attack brother and arms all right I hope
we make the right answer 3 2 1 be
let's go I said red you said Reds okay
for me again this is another one of it
depends this is exactly like the Disney
adult it just depends on how much right
you can like a lot of horror movies
which Sydney and Ari most certainly do
love the horror genre right love the
True Crime [__] I think that's fine but
when once you start to get to the point
of like you know you're actively trying
to like pursue cases or like you know
you
abely abh like pornp FMS that you can
find on thek [__] that's a red flag for
me right right but if you just like
horror as a genre I think it's fine uh
this is like pure no reason just feeling
I'm like I just don't like I I just get
a bad Vibe why personally why well I hey
I like Sydney Sydney's great but when
I'm when I'm like if I'm talking to
someone and they're like two the most
lovely people I know are
bigs of the hor the other one is John
super ipf you
know this is not me as like a red flag
as people I'm like to date someone who
likes horror too much for me I just
don't [__] with the vibe do you not like
horror I think it's like the worst genre
overall really consistently it gets the
worst [__] I mean there's a lot of [__]
horror films out there it's one of the
easiest types of films gen for genre it
generally has like the lowest quality of
most things because I mean for there
there's a lot of reasons but why you
know what I'm going to come here and
defend horror you can okay as a genre
I'm ha it I'm ha it what up as as a
genre yes I agree that uh there are a
lot of [__] horror films and they are
happen to be the ones that get the most
uh marketing and most attention like the
FNAF film that just came out for example
but I'd say as a genre horror has some
of the most conceptually interesting
ideas you can find in anywhere like most
genres which is why I'm a [__] [__]
but I'm one of those kinds of guys who I
love hearing about horror movies cuz I
like to experience horror without
experience horror experiencing horror
movies cuz they have such interesting
ideas I I am also a [__] uh but some of
the really good horror films I've
watched I've just absolutely loved as a
film just because it's so like I'm not
here out B saying there's no good horror
films film for film no I I I totally
agree with that and I think the problem
there you're treating is it's like a
[__] UFC fight yo pound for pound
pound for pound show me the genre sci-fi
dog [__] genre what's the ratio someone
tally it up dog [__] no I totally agree
like I think you know because of like
the whole b-grade horror thing and just
the fact that horror as a story and as a
type of film is probably one of the
easier genres to film for like Indie
creators and like you know Indie
directors and stuff like that yes there
is a lot of [__] out there a lot of
really amateur [__] that's boring and
stereotypical but whenever you get some
like really conceptually different and
just like thrilling and well written
stories in the horror genre an extension
of my hatred for the most popular well
not hatred but you know I I admittedly I
consume this but I I hate that I consume
this stuff and I hate the what True
Crime stuff yeah I hate I hate the yeah
true crime is the most popular horror
genre right now oh yeah um but you can't
look away no yeah but it's like it it
feels like there's really I and I always
say this all the time it feels I don't
it makes me feel weird I don't like that
we I mean I I said that right like at
the first [__] remember this a this I
said it before it was like super popular
now people are like oh it's it's super
popular you hate it now I'm
kidding no but like yeah yeah it's just
personal experience every person that
I've ever been with who is very into
horror bad vibes bad vibes bad vibes for
me personally oh I'm also the
commom yeah for me for me when I when I
see someone like that
uh I don't I don't think bad vibes I
just think man they are very morbidly
curious and um you know it's it's that a
lot of the times The Morbid curiosity
just takes over the logical brain
because they know it's like a lot of
people who I've met know it's just like
ah I you know I know I shouldn't look at
this have been a plague doctor back in
the
day yeah probably and she would have
loved it yeah like to me to me I'm not
someone who who's that morbidly curious
I've seen enough things to be like ah I
think my day would be happy if I didn't
see this one thing yeah that's good this
B yeah beige to me it's just a little
quirky yeah to me to me it's just like
one weird thing that someone obsesses
over if they're not hurting anyone over
it then I think it's fine yeah
difference a Disney adult and a horror
fanatic yeah oh my Lord to me the Disney
thing is mostly I think like the Disney
thing is more in line of with why you
put red as horror just not my vibes it's
I this is like cuz I think if you would
have we could have a genuine
conversation about like why all of these
are really not that bad yet but I feel
like we should be going off pure gut
like how we're feeling about it yeah
okay cuz that's how it should be because
this is your you're imagine you're
dating this person like I would just son
up my go I don't have to imagine
yeah balls who tell me don't date the
Disney adult I don't know why I just
wouldn't feel good about it I mean I
have no problem with being a Disney
adult I have no problem Mary being a
horror fanatic uh she just likes Kingdom
Hearts a little too much in my opinion
that's a red flag all right
all right